In what you've done with your life thus
far?
Is it giving you what you want?
When you look toward the future,
when you look at all this boring on out
here,
is there some place within yourself you
say,
Hey,
I know I need to be out there and not
arena.
I know I can do more than what I've been
doing.
I know there's some great music that I
have within me that I haven't brought
out here cause that's something that you
began to look at within yourself.
See,
I saved you.
Look at your life and if and if you're
not getting what you want,
you owe it to yourself to do something
differently.
You are.
If you're on a job,
85% they say of Americans,
go to jobs,
but they're unhappy.
If you're doing something eight hours a
day that you don't like,
it's not giving you what you want is not
giving you a strong feeling of
satisfaction and fulfillment.
You're miserable.
You hate to go there,
you're depressed just thinking about it.
You're saying the thank God it's Friday
song every week.
If that's what it is,
you are to your staff to start
strategically working to change
directions.
See,
but you know what most people do?
Most people will resist change.
Most people will fight change as if
change would be worse than what they're
experiencing.
See,
they know this.
They're familiar with this.
Most people will not challenge the
unknown.
They won't just step off there.
See they,
well see there are certain things has
got to be in place.
They got to see it all together and life
isn't like that.
That's not how you grow.
So as you look at your life,
you're saying,
I'm not getting one.
I want.
As you begin to look toward the future,
begin to know that whatever it takes for
you to create that,
you've got that in you.
If you've got that,
you've got genius in you,
you've got goodness in you,
you got creativeness in you.
If you decide to take the initiative to
change the current quality of your life,
I say to you that you will find that the
universe is on your side,
that life is on your side,
not.
Will it be turbulent?
Yes.
Would it be easy?
No.
We have some opposition.
Yes.
Will I make a lot of mistakes?
Will I get hurt?
Yes.
See,
a lot of people won't try anything
different in life because they don't
want to get hurt.
Let me tell you something.
It's too much pain to doc.
Pain is everywhere.
You can hide under here.
It will come where you are.
It's everywhere.
Viktor Frankl cause it unavoidable.
Suffering kept,
but most people spend their life not
wanting to deal with the pain of
rejection.
The pain of defeat,
the pain of being disappointed,
the pain of losing,
the pain of failure,
the pain of being criticized,
the pain of not being locked,
the pain,
the pain.
That's called life.
Life is don't pay this everywhere,
but that's why there is no gain without
pain
because it's the pain of regret.
That's your experience.
If I had it to do over again,
that's a pain.
Don't you know that something when you
know,
I was in a seminar once and this lady
stood up if I had my life to live over
again,
she talked about all of the things that
she would do and you can feel the pain
of regret,
regret.
She was still experiencing.
She was trying not to experience the
pain of defeat,
the pain of disappointment,
the pain of loss.
Okay?
The pain of lack of support
and she's still experienced pain.
It was right there.
We can't get around it.
Most people are governed by their
habits,
the fears and the opinions of others.
A lot of people never try anything
differently because they have been
convinced by people in their lives that
they value.
That'd be can't do it.
They're living within the context of the
opinions that other people have of then
the low expectations.
Many people doubt themselves because
when they thought about doing something
at some critical point in the life of
somebody they respected and honored
somebody,
they believed them,
somebody that they loved,
someone they trusted,
said,
you can't do that,
and they accepted that.
As you look at your life,
ask yourself the question,
what would your life be like?
What would your life look like if you
decided not to care what people thought
of you?
What would your life be like if you
decided to give up some of your fears?
decided to become courageous?
What would your life be like if you
decided to act on your dream?
If you did what you felt in your heart?
You know what courageous means?
Tom Ruskin and randy reads that this had
that courage comes from a French word,
which means of the heart.
How does it feel to you?
He says,
it's college.
You know it takes courage to lear says
most people go through life not allowing
themselves to step out because they
don't want to let go.
They don't want to be blown around.
They don't want to be moved.
The courage to face of lice,
whirling win of contradictions,
but courage to love yourself.
The courage to love that.
For years I was afraid to long the
courage to take a chance,
the courage to be who you are.
He says,
courage isn't for somebody else.
For metals.
Applause,
a moral depth.
Courage is what at that moment feels
most right for you.
Not just situational ethics,
but what feels right in your heart.
The word alcohol,
what feels right in your heart?
One great philosopher says,
car what's die?
Many times before their deaths,
the valiant never taste of death,
but once.
What does that be in the valley?
And people aren't afraid.
No,
no,
no.
It means that they experienced that here
and they move forward and move forward.
Any harm?
Many people are dead.
Not many people along their dreams to
die.
Many people applying the ideas,
delight,
Dorma and collect dust.
Many people have all this talent and
ability that they align to be embedded
inside of them,
that they will take with them to their
graves because they didn't have the
courage to be who they are.
And I say as you begin to look toward
the future and manifesting your
greatness,
it's going to take everything in you,
everything in you that your life
deserves.
The concentrated effort to begin to look
at.
How is it that I can express more of me?
How is it that I can bring my ideas out
here?
Now,
how is it and start living with a sense
of urgency?
Because you're here today.
You're gone today.
Life is unpredictable.
It's uncertain.
There are no guarantees,
no guarantees out here at all.
So holding back,
what are you waiting on?
Ask Yourself,
what's the benefit of your waiting?
What's the benefit of you're not living
your dream?
What's the benefit of not listening to
yourself?
Oh,
please listen to yourself.
You know the feelings that you started
listening to the feelings in your heart,
and I'm doing it now more everyday.
I find that my feelings,
I can trust them.
And I say to you
that as you look toward the future,
you look at life on a daily basis.
If there's something that you had been
given,
if you've heard something within
yourself that you know that what you're
doing now,
it doesn't fit you.
It doesn't work for you.
It's not giving you what you want and
there's something else that you want to
do.
Don't allow that inner doubt in you to
talk you out of it.
The bill,
a case on why you can't have it,
to tell you why you're not good enough.
You ignore that inner voice and all of
the external voices.
Don't judge the possibilities,
but what you can do based upon the
circumstances,
because the circumstances won't
determine who you are.
Don't determine what you're able to do
based upon your resources,
won't determine what's possible for you
based upon where your life is right now,
where your life is right now.
It's not you.
That's just what it is right now,
but the possibilities for you are
unlimited.
If you're in a rebuilding process,
it's unlimited.
If you're coming back from adversity and
devastation,
it's unlimited of what you can do.
That's the capacity of human beings.
It doesn't matter how many mistakes
you've made.
It doesn't matter how many flops you've
had,
doesn't matter how much money you've
lost.
In fact,
I see it only as an investment.
What you learned from life,
not losses,
but investments of what's possible for
you.
And I say to you that once you start
listening to yourself and as you begin
to act on your dream,
as you start just trying to find your
way,
doing what you can,
what you have,
you will start seeing things opening up
for you.
Started tracking people.
You say,
where'd it come from?
Things will start coming together.
Clicking for you.
You say,
whoa.
You start brainstorming.
Ideas will come out of nowhere as you
focus on it.
The key to it is to begin to focus on
what it is you want to do.
Why?
Let's,
why is that important?
Because as you focus on that which you
want to do,
that which we focus on,
that which we give out energy to,
it will begin to multiply.
It will began to expand.
It will begin to develop your
consciousness and out of that comes your
greatness.
Out of that comes a commitment.
Out of that comes a passion for life.
Out of that calm they special power that
you have in you that you haven't even
called on yet.
See,
the powers that we have will never
reveal themselves if we don't challenge
them.
If we don't put ourselves in the
position where we have to use them.
So one of the most important things is
reading a book that's a really
interesting book called instant
millionaire.
And the guy said,
put yourself in a position where you
can't retreat where it's do or die sake
or swell.
Here's what you'll find out.
You're developing credible swimming
skills.
You'll find yourself struggling unlike
you've ever seen before.
Through the inspiration of desperation,
you'll become more creative than ever
before.
So what is it?
How do we handle that whole piece?
Throw your whole self into it.
See,
most people go at it tentatively,
they don't give all their stuff.
They don't concentrate,
they don't put everything they've got in
them.
One Guy wrote a book called,
all you can do is all you can do and all
you can do if he know.
But he said,
make sure you do all you can do.
And if we're honest this evening,
we know that we haven't done all we can
do.
So as we look at the future,
we can decide that from this day
forward.
As I look at my personal relationships,
if I look at my professional
relationships,
if I look at my family relationships,
if I look at all the dimensions of my
life,
looking at myself mentally,
emotionally,
and spiritually,
I'm going to do all I can do to develop
me,
to bring my talent out here,
to make a contribution to life.